wait what about this this might be the
shrooms talking but what if we we have
real problems in America what if we made
them into video games and let kids solve
them
and then it would solve problems
all right well I'm just saying you know
there's two movies that's a Project X
with Matthew Broderick and Ender's Game
thank you jamo we pulled out Ender's
Game make a kid think he's playing a
game but he's actually like controlling
the whole [__] heart wasn't making
funny all right well the whole thing
just shut down if they just keep making
drones our drones fight each other yeah
remember we have like proxy wars
going after each other
we're trying to do a show here hanging
entertainment we just got here God damn
it you just got there yeah your face is
this [__] thing
Jesus Christ I thought you were Buddha
you look like one of those Eastern
Islands
[Music]
[__]
be so funny please tomorrow I just
deleted I just still can't believe
you're piling notes man and you insist
on keeping them in your pocket oh yeah I
got some new stuff on here you're gonna
get a bad back man oh yeah yeah you
shouldn't sit with anything in your back
pocket you have a solution just front
pocket I got my keys in there oh that's
good
see how that guy's sitting
with that fat wallet see how his back's
all [__] up that's like your back
right yeah that is my back that's what
I'm saying hold on trust me oh I [__]
myself
yeah can we get the dog in here
laughs